[Music]
in australia
a man has started a pretty unusual
business venture
only fans man's only fans only man
only man's only mans that's that's a
good one this probably
already exists does it no is it no that
sucks
but uh only men's only men's only
woman's
only fans matt has to be man's guys
around with fans
true how about only cans and it's like
different cans of soda
of different era nice i like it it
sounds like a museum
you go and visit the best to see cans
throw money at me i'm ready all right so
a man
has decided to rent out his parenting
services
to deadbeat dads he's a good dad i would
have needed that well i guess relative
to deadbeat he's got to be all right oh
right yeah true true that's pretty cool
it doesn't take much
to raise the bar from a deadbeat dad i
tell you that
very true and i don't know if this guy
has the credentials to
be in this oh no fear because
he's kind of deadbeat himself he never
had a kid he doesn't have a kid
oh he doesn't he's not exactly a dad but
he is
a rent a daddy is he serious about this
or is it a joke
uh i think it leads to a different it's
like it's like a
he's like a hooker but like male escort
yes yes so
here's his wait wait no no is it sexual
yeah what it kind of leads there oh [ __ ]
no so here's his ad i thought it was
like like
rent a daddy hey daddy right he saw he
poses
uh the problem right here he goes has
your baby daddy been acting up
yes baby daddy oh it's not for the kid
it's for the mom
well it's a little bit of both he's kind
of like a all-around
kind okay where do you need servicing
yeah it's like
daddy yeah it's like a rental zaddy you
know that's true
i'll [ __ ] your [ __ ] and then afterwards
i'll have a tea party with your kids
or vice versa whatever comes first
whatever you need yeah whoever never
helped you put them to bed and then i'll
put
you to bed how about that so he says
tired of him playing games does he put
drugs
and his mates before your kids get
yourself a rent-a-daddy
rental includes one or two weekends per
month
up to three activities of the kids
choice nice all right pretty wholesome
we'll attend all sporting events three
hours of instructional learning of
valuable life skills including
car maintenance and mowing the lawn
daycare
school drop off and pickups please note
family events and birthday parties are
extra facebook relationship status
extra family selfies extra
and this is where it starts getting a
little interesting 30 dollars per hour
standard rate 20
surcharge per hour sundays after 4 p.m
and sunday night dinner dates
payable by you private time is
negotiable
upon application kids are to be asleep
or absent from
premises cash debit
after pay what's after pay like well you
could do payment it's like a payment
system oh i see
uh damn key accepts the after pay and
zip pay available
contact me directly he's responsible
he's like if there's kids in the house
we are not [ __ ]
well no they have to be asleep he said
true or
away from the premises yes yeah yeah so
that's responsible
he's like i like it i'll make you feel
good but you got to be responsible mom i
like it
yeah i i wish they had this for like
grandma's like grandma and grandpa's
you know what do you mean like that
grandma can rent a grand
grand daddy yeah but not to [ __ ] grand
zaddy
granzad what is a grands ads
grand zed solo i'm sorry
so yeah this is like a random man yeah
it's like
he kind of does everything hubby dad
yeah like yo you need me to come over
help you with some chores
maybe play with your kids and then pound
that [ __ ] down
i got you girl that's like a after pay
thought though right like uh the
pound the [ __ ] seems like very much so
like it's only bottom like way down
here yeah it's really just kind of like
a like it's kind of like the happy
ending
right yeah really come for the massage
but like it's possible
he's a modern-day geisha he's not a
hooker yeah it's like asia is a great
word to put
doing all these
[Laughter]
how do we know that he's a good sure
rent a dad though
yeah i don't know i don't i mean i think
he hit the house
reviews yeah he's got like 4.9 out of
five stars maybe he has a yeah a sex
review
or not i'm not a sex review like well
that's where you're mine
well cause hookers have a sex review
thing they do yeah true it's like yeah
cares oh i i forgot because the site got
taken down by the fbi
oh [ __ ] but yeah i think it was called
like world sex review
but my my friend was like a super
whoremonger right and then he
showed me this whole entire world and
before even yelp came out this was like
in early 2000s he ratted him out to the
fbi
he was showing me no no he was showing
me all of these like yeah this one's
really good but i'm like i was like
isn't it kind of weird that like
there's like all these guys reviewing
their experience
and then like you kind of come in and
[ __ ] afterwards these dudes and then
he's like no no he's like
then it's kind of like they test it for
me and then
if all of the experience are similar
then i know like what the
it's like a he's like he's like i know
what the five-course meal is gonna be
he's a great has a great perspective and
i'm like what that's [ __ ] crazy man
but uh yeah it's an interesting world
but yeah i think the fbi went through
this whole like prostitution
investigation thing and they took down
all of these sites so interesting yeah
but then they they should have one for
zaddy's right yeah girls go on like yelp
and they're like man the way that he
cleans i have never met another dude
that could match
my [ __ ] quality of cleaning you know
or like they they gotta put good reviews
you know well the true test
is like let's say you have a kid that's
a [ __ ] face
there's a lot of kids that are [ __ ]
faces and see if you can like
actually restrain his temper and not
punch him in the face
how do you do that that's the tough part
and then and i think when you
when the kid is yours there is a
extra incentive right to like to punch
him in the face no no
to restrain yourself but when it's not
and it's just someone else's you know
i'ma be out of here in three hours
it's i don't know if i'm gonna be out of
here in three hours i just let him do
his thing yeah
i was like there'd be no opposite yeah
there'd be no discipline in reverse
mine's different cause i'm like this
one's mine i don't want to hurt him oh
that's cute but the one that someone
else is on
the [ __ ] out at 2 hours and 59 minutes
he's gonna slap
the crap out and then run i like this
like
there's already confrontation was like
has your baby daddy been acting up
so potential baby daddies are still in
the picture
and he's just gonna like come over and
just like oh i was rented i just want to
let you know no
i thought it was like baby daddies but
they're separated like that's what it
sounds
daddy but it's like not like you know
what they say
they say that name but it doesn't mean
that they're together well isn't this
kind of like uh
like the big brother program or
something it's like an adult
but they don't [ __ ] the mom i know they
don't [ __ ] or i mean maybe who knows
but these days you don't know that's
true they're not getting paid right it's
just a volunteer kind of thing
yeah what if the kid what if kids like
fall in love with their rented dad
though
oh that's so sad that's their fault man
you gotta run them off or dead
to buy option you know rent to buy yeah
mom why are you leasing he's not tax
deductible
i'd be like kid you need to learn how to
manage and compartmentalize your
feelings dude
i don't like this kind of immaturity and
life just hit that kid
yeah i know he's like you see the box
that you hold inside your heart put
everything in there and let's never talk
about it now let's go mow a lawn
and not talk at all does this guy also
step to other baby daddies
like step collect some child support for
me oh [ __ ] i don't know
oh that'd be a service he looks like a
guy that could collect child support
yeah he looks kind of he's not like an
all-around guy like i could trust him
mopping my floors but
cooking a nice like rack of lamb but
still going out
and collecting the [ __ ] it's like a
bounty hunter
yeah what a hero i love this guy he's so
smart
he's like an all-around dude you know
true he could come home and [ __ ]
pound that [ __ ] down true do you think
when he posted this
it was like let me just put a lot of
fluff up here
but i'm what i'm really trying to get at
is just this bottom part of
pound puss it down private time whatever
you call it i don't know i thought about
something yeah he thought about family
gatherings i think it's well thought out
like even the marketing approach right
like a good marketer will
will solve a problem that you already
have that you didn't even realize that's
great it's like
here's the problem sentence it was like
captivating he
like laid it all out he has his terms i
think it's i
do have a baby daddy who's been acting
him
it's like an infomercial do you have a
baby daddy
that just doesn't [ __ ] come around
and he just smokes
crack all day but then he's got like a
really really small disclaimer at the
bottom it's like i'm not sticking around
for love not doing this but i will beat
your kids
[Laughter]
i kind of want to like save his number
and then call him on myself if i [ __ ] up
you know i'm like man i [ __ ] up i
could text them hey can you come beat my
ass i haven't been a good baby daddy you
calling me picks up you say hey what's
up tyka how are you doing
what else bart yeah joe
the disclaimer is like may cause
attachment issues
to children family members you might get
your heart broken girl because i'm just
here
rented oh that's true dang it's good
that's a pretty cool service i feel like
there's so many things you can kind of
rent now
like people are buying cuddling time and
like
all that stuff yeah and it's like it's
kind of sad
but is it though because to get that
right
you have to deal with so much more
baggage sometimes
there's a give and take like sometimes
you just want to cuddle and then you're
just kind of like it's like shut the
[ __ ] up i don't want to hear your
problem right do i gotta like cuddle but
then like deal with their problems and
stuff it's got to be like a la carte
itemizing of charges
it's like cuddle only no talk five
dollars oh yeah like tell me one problem
add five more dollars you want me to
respond [ __ ] fifteen dollars you know
what i mean like
i'm dead no this is gonna be easy it's
four months
you just have like i'm getting spooned
right because you're paying me because
i'm obviously a little stupid you know
you're a little i'm a little spoon right
somebody's paying for my cuddle services
they want to tell me something
you pull up you bring it in you do that
you're all like you're all like
if you have the credit card square ready
to go
okay all right continue tell me your
problem
what do you think ah what i think
that's time the menu i love it uh
and it's like well i'll give you two for
one all right cool
so if you want the you know full package
buyout it's like this price and
we could just talk about anything
they give you it's like this is one ply
toilet paper and then this is kleenex
with lotion or you want a chivalrous
handkerchief
fifty dollars keep the hanky for an
extra point yeah that's right
that's tough there's gotta be such a
formal concept to it and then
and then there's no boundary crossing
because you know yeah more traditional
white beater location a hundred dollars
if you want a black eye oh [ __ ] shut up
stop crying
some people want different stuff i don't
know just trying to keep doctors open
i mean technically people do want that
right if they're in the s
m world yeah there is a world there we
go there is a world
you think that there's a rent to mommy
or is that just like there's way too
many people
it's called a nanny oh true all right
yeah we got this guy should just be on
nano nano
the new nano plus
[Music]
you